we have this uh we have this tweet from
chris hayes he says was just checking on
what happened in the 1946 midterms as
the nation readjusted after a historic
society why disruption and inflation was
eight percent don't google it so i
googled it yeah of course and we found
that uh the 1946 election resulted in
republicans picking up 55 seats to win
majority control
well times they are changing it's very
different these days the parties
represent very different ideas but i
think it is fair to say yeah i mean
maybe that much could you imagine
if we get blindsided by a republican
super majority in the house
how many how many seats would they need
to win for a super majority well there's
no there's no such thing as a house
super majority right like because it's
just fit it's 50 plus yeah right whoever
gets 50 plus one who vote it's the
senate's your majority would be 60
i think or 61 or no 60. um and we could
i don't think that's even conceivable
given the map so right how many seats do
you guys think the republicans are going
to need to pick up to keep not doing
anything
oh man probably all of them you know but
but hold on hear me out if the
republicans actually are able to cynic
let's be real if they're able to pick up
like 55 seats
and just change the shape of the house
of the house representatives then
they'll probably do nothing
yeah no well i mean
they're not going to be able to do
anything meaningful because biden's
going to veto it right we're still going
to have a democratic president until
they can impeach
that's what they can do they can do
investigations they should make the
january 7th committee and i actually
think that's
you know one better i have heard i've
heard whispers that kevin mccarthy is
actually going to like go hard on the
investigations and there's there's sort
of like the democrats have been have
pissed him off so much over the past
like two years that he's actually going
to go like make them really pay for it a
bit i don't believe it i don't know
that's right here
if they make the mistake of making
mccarthy speaker of the house he's going
to be like i'm going to go after these
investigations and then he's going to be
standing tall in the moment they're like
and mccarthy has he's going to go oh
and then he's just going to be like
armed tired yeah i don't know that's
more
i worry about it but who knows who knows
i mean it could be
i mean that's what they're gonna do like
i mean i know there's they're not gonna
i think there is definitely like a lot
of resistance like i heard matt gates
talking about this like there's a lot of
resistance into doing what the paul ryan
republican house did during obama which
was just pass a bunch of bills that they
knew never were going to go anywhere and
then find themselves yeah subpoenas
hunter biden
under oath lots and lots of subpoenas
you know get to the bottom get to the
bottom of russia gate get at the bottom
of 100 bucks biden testify
yeah no just like just embarrassing they
would still call it unprecedented sure
sure here's what happens mccarthy
primary the guy
mcconnell whatever senate i don't care
who they are just get them out use
primary primary primary primaries across
the board get rid of everybody
bye-bye
i'm looking up ideally i'm trying to put
my mind in the heads of people in 1946
when they did this it was post-world war
ii so they're just getting out of this
traumatic world war uh harry truman was
truman republican german was a democrat
truman had not been elected right he was
a vice president
um and he
was uh you know when when franklin
roosevelt died right before the end of
world war ii he became president so
um what caused all these what caused all
these people to get voted in was it i
mean just the end of the war must have
been such a paradigm i mean it real a
lot of the sitting leaders got thrown
out of office right winston churchill
got thrown out of all this can i just
say something real quick in england uh
don't the democrats claim the parties
switched in the latest yes they claim
that during the civil rights era the
party switch so so how was him after so
if the party's switched what chris is
actually saying when he says don't
google it is that he believes democrats
are going to
win yeah maybe they don't believe it i
think i think i don't know it's more
that he thinks that like the the party
in power is going to take a beating yeah
right right right like basically this is
this kind of stuff people are people are
not happy and want something different
and that i mean that happened right
winston churchill literally is the guy
who won the war the guy who's the hero
of britain and he got tossed out in a
general election
like yeah they hated him in the early
days because they're like all he talks
about is war and he's like i'm telling
you the germans are going to declare war
he's like ah that silly man and then
finally when the war broke out there we
need them now they brought them in when
they won the war like we don't need them
anymore yeah
man peace in our time huh what a what
what an amazing quote
that's neville chamberlain right right
yes
yeah exactly wow um that's why i wrote
peace and prosperity because they're not
the same thing great book that was a
fascinating take on world war ii from
britain's perspective called the phony
victory by peter hitchens and his basic
thesis is britain was in effect one of
the losers of the war um that britain
prior to the war had some pretensions of
being a great power and post-war they
were a vassal of the united states yep
um and they better know it and they
basically like found themselves in a war
situation where they were basically
doomed their only hope was the united
states coming to save them and oddly
enough franklin roosevelt and the united
states
managed to extract major major
concessions from britain throughout that
period when they were in that really
difficult period in like 1940 um in
order to in for to be willing to help
the united kingdom what kind of we were
still not that happy about
bases oh they gave us their military
bases they had military bases in like
newfoundland and like in canada
and they just we just said you want our
old destroyers like our old retro you
know not very useful destroyers give us
your land give us your military bases
whoa you know what that the king was it
a king at the time was it
yeah well they had i mean it was that
was also that was under chamberlain
right when they were starting to do i
think no that was probably under church
when they were doing len lease
i'm not sure i'm actually not sure who
was the reigning monarch at the time uh
king george so was george signing over
the land
no it wouldn't mean it
it wasn't up to him right it's at that
point it's still a constitutional
monarchy with technically prime minister
dominating the technically the king
could
yeah but it was still it was still at
that point where it's like the you know
the prime minister's running the
government of britain and so it was on
chamber neville chamberlain and
churchill to make the decision but i
mean they were just they were in a
terrible position i mean they could they
found a way to stop
a seabourn invasion by hitler's germany
but they had no hope i mean they got
kicked out of continental europe had to
flee from dunkirk and the miracle of
dunkirk was that they managed to
evacuate yeah you know most of their
forces
and i mean they had no hope of trying to
recall you know reconquer continental
europe
um
you know i mean it and it's one thing
it's funny like actually i've read some
my grandfather's letters from that
period when before the united states
entered the war after dunkirk and he's
doing the calculations on like america
entering the war and it just is just
staggeringly awful like because at that
point also the soviet union's not in the
war against germany right and so people
are talking about the united states
entering
and
uh
it's like that's not they're not going
there's no way that we could possibly do
this because it's just you know us
versus nazi germany and we're having to
invade on a seabourn invasion
which is crazy yeah which like and hit
my my grandfather's conclusion like this
would be insane like we can't do it
man i mean if you think about it
storming the beaches was
nuts yeah i think it would have made no
sense at all had the soviet union not
already been in the war and been you
know grinding up the german army
yeah i mean you know people often forget
how the communists save the world and
then they just malign those poor soviets
or soviets but that's actually something
i know hey man we helped in world war ii
and it's like yeah but you like killed a
ton of people before world war ii so it
doesn't make you the good guys yeah yeah
also forgetting the fact that they were
the ones who wanted to keep working with
hitler until he betrayed them yeah right
barbarossa when the germans went in to
went into russia
they're like hey wait you're not
supposed to attack us i guess we have no
choice yeah i think it's funny like how
many how many tens of millions of people
did the u.s kill in the early 1900s was
it none
i think so i mean i don't know obviously
people died at the hands of the united
states but it wasn't tens of millions
right well you had the nazis we know
what they did and you're the soviets we
know they did and then here we are like
let's team up with one of them against
the other it's the weirdest it's the
craziest thing to me that like they're
both just extremely awful yeah but then
we ended up having to fight what 60 70
years a cold war proxy wars all over the
planet because the soviets were very
much bad guys yep
really i mean really it comes down to uh
you know the fact that hitler declared
war in the united states that like if
you're looking at the you know there was
another very fascinating bit of this
book that i thought was really
interesting there's that window between
december 7th 1941 and i think four days
later
where hitler declares war in the united
states and britain was freaking out
because they thought we were just going
to go to work with japan
and they that's where all our resources
were going to go that's where every all
the military investment was going to go
and britain was just going to have to
hold out nazi germany on its own
and then hitler declared war on us and
all of a sudden like they just
breathe a sigh of relief well i mean the
us was like we don't really need to
worry about war with japan because we
got nukes we need we need our ground
forces in europe
your timings are on we didn't have nukes
fully developed until like 45 um and
that it wasn't obvious in 1940
41 that that was going to be like a game
changer they had a meeting roosevelt uh
stalin and uh churchill i think i think
stalin was involved too where they might
have just been uh churchill and
roosevelt they decided that they were
going to focus american war efforts they
were all agreed on europe we're not
we're not we're going to worry about
japan until later well i mean they just
agreed that the united states would take
the the like the ore in japan and that
some of most of the american resources
would go but i mean we were still i mean
we we built a hell of a carrier force
like we spent a lot of money and energy
on japan too i think strategically
europe was more allies and more forces
to help if you if you liberate europe
you get more assistance in the rest of
the war right and i mean i think it was
ultimately a priority i think like over
japan in the in the pacific theater uh
but japan still got a ton of attention
it's crazy how much japan lost because
they went to war in this way oh it was a
a horrible horrible decision they were
doomed from the outset in terms of their
industrial capacity i mean you know more
more nerdy stuff but like from basically
like we dwarfed their naval production
by like ten to one
um just for their theater right like we
were able to also produce everything we
need for europe and then dwarf japan's
naval production like ten to one and uh
that's it's a naval war like right
carriers are
you know carriers are everything and we
just you know they produce maybe like
six workable carriers when we produce
like 50 or 60 or something i mean it was
just i heard that they were on the verge
of surrendering before we dropped the
bombs on them is that true
yeah well i mean
they were on the you know it's it's not
clear which caused the surrender which
it was the russians finally declaring
war on japan
or uh and deciding to invade through
manchuria um or the the bombs right
because the first bomb went off and they
didn't they didn't surrender and then
russia declared war
i think it was i'm not sure of the exact
timing they may have been deciding after
the first bomb wow it may have been a
meeting of you know
the japanese saying like who do we want
to be occupied by
yeah they might that i think it was
really once the russians invaded i think
that might have been plus the bomb but
the russians invading was sort of like
oh we're screwed right we lose did they
organize the american government and the
russians like we're going to drop a bomb
when you invade like we're going at them
with everything i don't remember if that
was it i think honestly at that point
russia might have been opportunistic
because russia wanted a seat at the
table with japan to negotiate
territorial concessions and so stalin
might have been kind of opportunistic of
like oh this we think this war is
probably going to wrap up soon let's get
in on the game and ensure that our
territorial claims are respected thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there